Michael Cohen's a hundred and thirty
thousand dollar payment to stormy
Daniels is raising new legal questions
for him and the Trump campaign Paula
Reid is also at the White House Paula so
explain this because stormy Daniels
calls it hush money but why would the
FEC care about it why could it become
something that's a legal matter
well the big question is whether or not
this had anything to do with the
election
this is an affair that had occurred
about a decade prior but just eleven
days before the election she receives
this hundred and thirty thousand dollar
payment so the question for federal
investigators would be was this money to
keep her from talking during the
election and if it was you have possibly
two legal problems one is that this
amount would have far exceeded the
individual contribution limit for mr.
Cohen and the other issue is that we
don't really know exactly where this
money came from which could potentially
violate the disclosure requirements
under federal law now Paula why would
the Special Counsel Robert Muller be
interested in this well it's not clear
so far that he is it's possible we know
from sources that he is looking into how
the campaign was financed we also know
that he is asked witnesses about mr.
Cohen he's also asked her documents
related to some events that he was
involved in but you have to go back to
the specific mandate that Muller was
given and that was to investigate the
Russian government's interference in the
2016 campaign so it's very hard to see
how this would fit into that but if he
came in across any evidence of criminal
wrongdoing he could certainly give that
to the Justice Department to handle on
their own all right Paula thank you so
much